the gyro can experience did you ever see
that uh that Tom Cruise going to be
about Barry seal yes it's all about that
it's all about a few Cowboys rogue CIA
agents that decided tried wedding Kayla
ones in that movie for like five minutes
and he steals the whole [ __ ] thing
well whose lays he places his wife's
younger brother oh yeah they're like the
little degenerate dick [ __ ] yeah he was
awesome he's a great he's a funny dude
that's a lot like the bluegrass
conspiracy you know about that what's
with that bluegrass there was basically
was a Lexington Kentucky police officer
oh man it was slowly up till there's a
governor's office
yeah and it was it was deep in Kentucky
politics for years and years and years
and he he was he was flying a plane
little prop playing with weed and and
like money millions of dollars in
cocaine he crashed in Knoxville
Tennessee and they found on everything
they didn't know as a police officer
until he died and he was like he jumps
out of the plane with a parachute with
the coke strapped to him the way the
[ __ ] the shoe touchy loafers they found
him on the ground with his chute half
open I'm just like yeah like a powder
coke yeah and a bear also ate all the
cocaine and died right a big strawberry
shortcake just laying there in our horse
farm field you know there's pictures of
all how much coke does it take to kill a
bear it says how much he ate I don't
know if top of my head oh poor thing I
think they have it stuffed in Lexington
that's a really good book
you should read that book bluegrass
conspiracy yeah wanted the true story
but it small state level corruption at
the utmost level and rescue bear story
the legendary cocaine bear of Kentucky
that's Wow is that the bear they mounted
him wow that's he's gonna [ __ ] inside
out his Nexus cocaine bear I think
that's like a gold chain
it's like he's a rapper look he's got
his hat sideways he's gonna [ __ ] sign
rise next his cocaine bear it's all gold
bluegrass I gotta read that I definitely
had heard about the bear eating the coke
the berry seals one is a terrible one
because the reason why they found out
about is because these two kids found
the coke drop they found the coke and
they wound up murdering these two kids
when they went to achieve the coke and
they put their bodies on the railroad
tracks and they told the parents that
the kids got high and fell asleep on the
where of the railroad tracks but the
parents did an independent autopsy and
they found stab wounds and the kids you
know it's really [ __ ] up also what
would give that away I've seen that when
like transients or bums get ya come in
on you know it's always a part of art we
would have to find like young kids and
[ __ ] playing hop car and you know doing
the gutter rat lifestyle and a thousand
dollar [ __ ] North Face parkas and [ __ ]
usually when you do him in you're gonna
die right but like bums would come in on
the trains and this didn't happen re
orders over the North guard this guy he
thought they were done with the movement
you know you took 5700 foot steel with
[ __ ] 45,000 horsepower on the front of
it like when it starts moving it's very
sudden and hard so if you just go to
stand up all that thing all of a sudden
when it starts rolling and then you you
lose your footing and you fall down the
tracks from the cars but when you get
run over by a train it's not bloody and
messy because the especially if it's
been on the mainline it's rolling really
hard and hot
you put a limb on a track or a body or a
corpse all that weight and friction and
heat when it goes over it just cuts it
like butter and Carter eyes does
everything like pisses you off like
sausage so we find pieces not a mess
just pieces oh my god unless you hit a
[ __ ] cow or something stand in the
middle of track and going 70 miles an
hour and then you just [ __ ] and guts
hanging off the front of the train does
that even slow the train down no no not
at all a cow doesn't say it's less than
a bug on your windshield
yeah could you imagine being in the
[ __ ] seat the driving seat I've done
it have you you've actually seen
operated locomotives I've never hit a
cow but I've definitely driven a train
but what did was the biggest thing you
had I didn't really hit anything nothing
no I mean imagine though being we were
switching I only operated one within the
yard so I'm probably like 35 40 miles an
hour tops but on the mainland when
they're really rolling they're doing
like 70 72 miles an hour like I said
it's 50 you know a mile and a half long
train with five four or five locomotives
on the front of it all 30,000 horsepower
each so look I mean you'd it's a bag of
[ __ ] blood man you're not even gonna
but it just like do they have special
fronts that are designed to hit things
like that yeah it's a big giant steel
plow it's designed to push ten feet of
[ __ ] snow out of the way it has to
whoa yeah so like essentially like those
things that semis used for deer on the
the middle of the night but it's
actually a big steel shovel with like an
axe wedge in it whoa and it just kind of
just hangs and it sits about six inches
off the rail itself and its whole idea
is to just splatter every wish anything
out of the way and destroy it so keep
the train from derailing because the
only thing holding those things on the
rail the inner flange of a wheel set you
know it's there's like a little
three-quarter inch lip that kind of
hangs over on the inside of the rails
yeah so it's all just gravity and
downforce
keeping that thing going so you could
put like a brick technically you could
take anything a piece of [ __ ] metal
or a car jack and just lay it on that
thing when that train hits it at 70
miles an hour it's coming off the rail
and everything behind it is still going
70 miles an hour stacking up behind it
and I mean you go you don't think about
every time you pull up to a crossing in
the city and you see a train go by ten
miles now and there's like 20 tankers on
there full of raw chlorine you could
really [ __ ] some [ __ ] up if you knew
what you were doing you know kill the
whole city you derail that train
we have we'd have to think about that
and like Homeland Security would come
out and we have to have courses and [ __ ]
but you have so many miles of track oh
yeah you make sure that nobody does
anything our crews that drive that track
on daily basis and and repair things and
do you freak me out
[ __ ] training that's why I quit the job
if we watched enough of those things
happen right in front of me and that was
my job to clean him up and get a crane
out there at a [ __ ] cot in my office
I would live at the yard for three or
four days until we got everything
repaired and back together and rolling
but like you know two or three times
we'd be sitting out there in the middle
of switching leaves this happened where
I being a pickup truck at night or
during the daytime like with one of the
guys I work with you know maybe it's a
guy you're tired you're trying to get
done early and you got a bunch of empty
cars on the back and the dude puts the
throttle down before the air goes
through the system always rear the train
so you know you got this dead weight and
thinks I'll [ __ ] it I got three
locomotives I can push it'll be okay
until the when they designed the system
100 plus years ago nothing has changed
since then it's a very primitive
functional air brake system design you
hook all these hoses up from the front
to the back
it runs air through which allows the
brakes to release so then the engineer
can control those brakes well if the air
doesn't go all the way to the back the
brakes are still on those cars so when
all this horsepower pushing rolling
metal hits metal that what does not want
to roll it just buckles up in a teepee
almost instantaneously goes off and you
won't even feel it if you're 30 cars up
that you're pushing [ __ ] into the dirt
and it's all just pile on the top of it
of itself and like I want like two
seconds I watched this train go from
being on the track to literally digging
out a 10-foot trough of earth and just
just placing it and I think like every
day me or one of my guys is standing
right there I was like I'm gonna go
write songs dude
good thinking yeah yeah very good
thinking it's a good job but
yes you look somewhere someone is on a
[ __ ] train listening to this right
freaking out
they're just about to go to sleep I'll
just listen to Sturgill Simpson's garage
songs brother
[Applause]